qui et c'est joli bébé ricky bonjour
week-end moi je m'appelle aurora
oh
ajayi
tiens
petit régal vous sentez par an
[Musique]
ma moi je ne suis pas ta
diana
qu'est ce que je vais faire de toi
[Musique]
m
attention accroche-toi arrêté
[Musique]
comme chaque année il va nous falloir
migrer avant l'arrivée de l'hiver
tous ensemble nous volerons en formation
vers le grand lac en afrique des temps
meilleurs
les longs et périlleux
[Applaudissements]
salut tout le monde
ricky bien tu connais cet oiseau si elle
me connaissez ma mère l'eau douce
le mieux serait peut-être de reporter le
départ le temps que tu règle des
problèmes de famille
je n'ai aucun problème de famille
riquier il ya une chose que ta mère
enfin aurora aurait dû te dire il ya
longtemps avant quelque chose eh bien tu
es un moineau pas une cigogne tu peux
pas migré avec nous ta place est ici
avec les autres moines au jeu failli
marquer quel sens de l'humour à toi
alors
bourges reparti
[Musique]
regardez les mois
le prédateur et sa proie veulent se
rendre gibril tort je m'appelle actifs
et voici au lien voici olga et oleg quoi
oh oui je vois on est un peu que de nom
pardon mais c'est l'équipe qui se prend
pour une cigogne beau mais bien sûr que
c'est une cigogne voyez ce port de tête
cet inimitable et weygand aussi ça fait
plaisir merci enfin quelqu'un tu sais
quoi et le parc on pourrait savoir titi
aux mille excuses
dimitri perruches disco fantastique on
va saveurs de paille est le plus éminent
professeur de la paix j'ai entendu les
échos de votre petite prise de bec je
reprenais je peut vous emmener à
gibraltar
figurez vous que je me rends moi même
laisse pas une incroyable coïncidence
est ce qu'un oiseaux domestiques irait
faire là-bas et bien je dois me produire
sur scène en l'honneur de l'arrivée des
migrateurs ont festival de chiberta et
le seront dans le train avant d'avoir pu
dire 10 collaborer qu'est ce que c'est
un train
ce ca